los indocumentados en Estados Unidos
También tienen caras y nombres él es
Denis Javier Hidalgo Parra carpintero
venezolano que huyó de su país en 2016
cansado de la grave crisis económica y
social atravesó nueve países en búsqueda
de su sueño americano y enfrentó el peor
de los miedos en el tapón del Darién
Al momento de ingresar yo a la selva
verdad eso fue fuerte fuerte por como le
comentó la lluvia los gritos de los
animales de gente muerta niños ahogados
fue una experiencia Horrible Horrible
al segundo día a mí se me pierde mi hijo
No sé cómo me descuidé yo por ayudar a
otras personas y mi hijo se me perdió
eso fue a las 2 de la tarde
yo duré prácticamente cinco horas sin
saber de mi hijo
buscándolo cuando me decían que ella lo
diera por perdido que siguiera mi camino
porque no había vuelta atrás el guía no
te va a esperar fueron horas
desesperadas pero Javier pudo Localizar
a su hijo en la selva y continuar La
travesía una fortuna que no todos los
migrantes tienen llegó a Texas estado
gobernado por el republicano y que en
Octubre de 2022 decidió enviarlo junto
con cientos de personas más a Nueva York
ellos me dijeron que hiciera la cola la
línea
y ahí nos dieron unos alimentos
súper bien o trataron Y fue cuando nos
montaron en el bus tardamos tres días
para llegar a Ciudad Nueva York
al momento que llegamos en la ciudad de
Nueva York llegamos a la 42 me acuerdo
Yo perfectamente
Mira eso es algo inexplicable porque tú
te vas y tú sientes esa buena vibra esas
personas que quieren ayudar que nacieron
con ese don personas como Javier Hidalgo
Parra terminan convertidos en peones de
una guerra política entre republicanos y
demócratas los conservadores buscan
presionar a Estados con gobiernos
progresistas con el envío de
indocumentados desde el sur historia que
los gobernadores de Texas y Florida
prometen repetir una vez expire el
título 42